bevor es mit dem video losgeht muss ich
noch eine kurze sache sagen und zwar die
geschichte die ich erzähle ist bisschen
ja krass es vielleicht nicht ganz
jugendfreie deswegen für die ganz jungen
unter euch zeit so gut es gibt dieses
video am besten also ist jetzt nicht
über krasses aber ich möchte mich das
ganz junge leute jetzt das wiedersehen
und dann irgendwann mit überfordert sind
deswegen wenn ihr so unter 1314 seite
ist das video vielleicht nicht für euch
deswegen einfach als ich jetzt maßnahme
vielleicht irgendwie weg oder so weil
ich mir vorher gesagt dass niemand sich
nachher denkt psa aber jetzt viel spaß
mit dem video service skills und
herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen video
heute muss ich euch eine kleine
geschichte erzählen
der ganze spaß hat sich gestern abend
ereignet das ist so surreal was da
passiert ist also ist alles damit
angefangen heute dass ich gestern nach
hausarbeit geschrieben und im ganzen tag
schon seit zwei wochen das ja diese
hausarbeit wichtig für die uni schreiben
musste ihr wisst ja ich studiere
nebenbei ja 12 uhr mitternacht bei
abgabe und ich habe es geschafft hab das
ding rechtzeitig abgegeben nach die
messebauer digger geil fast geschafft
ist eine auswahl abgegeben
gern mal was georgi hat mir aus gerne
mal raus und macht irgendwas cool ist
dass das finden wolfsgeheul halter war
das feld aber gerade jemanden gelungen
einfach so ein wolf hat nur so viel mit
mittendrin gut wenn man es 58 da kann es
auch schon mal boscolo geben würde ich
sagen die leute sehen dass wir jetzt
auch schneidend sein für euch latzhose
und dann fahre ich nach wien zu wenig
und das sind von hier aus einfach
sechseinhalb stunden in 640 kilometer
ich heute noch bahn muss und wir haben
jetzt nur deswegen gefallen gerade so
wie soll das überhaupt gehen auf jeden
fall heute fallen mit der geschichte
ganz vorne hat 4 20 uhr ich hab die
hause weiter vergeben froh ich bin happy
alles klar ich noch nicht fertig greift
mit meinem kumpel dann gehen wir raus
und momentan ist bei mir in meiner stadt
so ne art volksfest
also was wir gemacht haben uns getroffen
ich begrüße den nicht sagte bach gut
also wir treffen uns sie begrüßen uns so
hague nach dieses volksfest gegangen
alles gut alles easy es war schon mega
später laufen dahin holen und bioland
festzelt alles easy stehen da so
unterhalten uns alles cool alles super
übrigens todesstern das wird auch im
stall unterhalten uns bestimmt zu 45
minuten
als dann einer hinter uns sagt so hey
jungs habt ihr flächen zigaretten wie
bei der sony wir brauchen nicht mehr so
ok alles klein war sympathisch deswegen
habe ich angesprochen und wieso er
weiter unterhalten aber zwei anderen
leuten da irgendwie in das war ein ganz
normaler typ der weiß nicht so mich
nicht wie komisch oder so man es nicht
erwartet so wie seine unschuldige bürger
also wir haben uns nichts dabei gedacht
hatte noch zwei andere fallen dabei
diesen dann nach einer weile wegen wie
ist aber noch geblieben habe ich mit ihm
unterhalten
weiter so herr jungs ihr seid mir
sympathisch ich lade dich auf dem 4 1
alles klar
da überlegt okay wo hat in diesen
kämpfen und diese uhrzeit noch eine bar
auf müsst euch vorstellen dadurch dass
ich die arbeit ist mit 12 abgegeben habe
und in der zeit auch also bis 4 uhr wach
war um die arbeit zu schreiben hatte ich
mein rhythmus total verschoben als ich
dachte mir so halb neun uhr abends dabei
nur und janka hat um 1 uhr alles tut das
wisst ihr vielleicht wenn in einem café
und dann haben wir irgendwann gefunden
die belegen könnten gehen dann dahin
unterhalten uns auf dem weg erzählt er
schon ewig viele ewig viele geschichten
von irgendwelchen schlägereien von
irgendwelchen häusern die er besitzt in
nicht ab ok mit dem moment
alleingelassen ich dachte alles ok kommt
er ist vielleicht angetrunken was weiß
ich wenn ihr mit den mitgliedern sind
mit dem monster in die wahl gegangen und
haben uns hingesetzt herr meint so
erlebt seinen aus kommt dann so eine
halbe stunde später wieder eine also ihr
müsst etwas vorstellen
wir saßen hier in so einer ecke okay
hier in der ecke und da drüben ist
direkt am tresen dass es keine riesige
bar ist keine bahnhofshalle und es ist
auch keinen kern flughafen rollfeld das
ist einfach eine kleine bar von unseren
sitzplatz bis zum tresen sind fünf meter
und er hat für diese fünf metern was zu
trinken zu holen eine halbe stunde
gebraucht
ohne witz ja aber irgendwann kam dann
wieder und hatte mir die ganze flasche
geholt und dann dann fing so die
seltsame sachen andere hat angefangen zu
erzählen von noch mehr von irgendwelchen
schlägereien und keine ahnung und ganz
komischen sachen und dann irgendwann ist
mein kumpel abgehauen weil er keinen
bock mehr hatte dann sagst nur noch ich
alleine um diesen typen da der mir so
ein bisschen suspekt war heißt
verdächtig habe die wege nicht wirklich
getraut aber dinge die passieren einfach
mal raus geht trifft man leute alles
klar so dass immer weiter heute
unterhalten
er malt ja irgendwo herkommen setzen
zwar über die jungs da kenne ich alles
klar dass mich rüber und das waren schon
so ja ich will jetzt keine stereotypen
beschwören aber das war so richtig breit
gebaute typen in schwarzen lederjacken
ausländischer abstammung so wo man sich
denkt okay vielleicht lege ich nicht mit
erinnern das waren offensichtlich seine
freunde ist man seine kumpels und dann
setze ich mich zu denen unterhalte mich
mit denen leute ein großteil von dem was
dieser gesagt haben kann ich eigentlich
gar nicht erzählen
das kann ich euch nicht erzählen weil es
nicht jugendfrei ist alles mögliche
kanal und die akademische stories über
die ich kann sich sagen ich kann sich
sagen ich wusste wissen wir die machen
sollte ganz ehrlich ich wusste einfach
nicht was mit ihm machen sollte was mit
den reden sollte und dann irgendwann
meint einer von den leiden da so hey was
machst du so ich so ich studiere an der
uni
jaja genauer gesagt vier an der uni
studiert und ja also wenn du einen der
und der uni willst kannst ja auch leute
wenn da irgendwelche leute mal bock
haben zu
dann kann ich euch da weiterhelfen ich
habe drei frauen und bleibt so dicker
fehler betrachten scheiße jetzt sitzen
damit irgendwelchen zuhältern am tisch
junge junge junge dokumentation okay ist
echt brenzlig vielleicht sollten jetzt
sollten jetzt abbauen was eine ganz
komische runde irgendwie als sehr dass
mir meine so erhöht seine kollegen was
dann schickte mir vorbei dachte ich mir
so lieber eher sinken
hab ich zu mir selbst design bau einfach
ab was hier ja das hab ich dann auch
gemacht ich hab da wir haben ein echter
viele leute wenn ich hier noch eine
halbe stunde länger sitzen bleibe
dann habe ich morgen mehrere vorstrafen
auch eine schwarze lederjacke
wobei ihr euch jetzt schon um euch
sitzen leute die einfach aussehend wie
verbrecher und irgendjemand die an dem
abend getroffen habe ich eine coole
coole stelle ich den vor und denkt ich
denke ich muss hier raus ich muss hier
raus was habe ich dann gemacht nachdem
er diese geschichte gedacht hatten
diesem angebot dachte ich mir so einfach
nein hab meine beine in die hand
genommen und bin wirklich abgehauen
alter noch so eger bleibt noch ein
bisschen da nicht so nie waren so viele
morgens
ich muss hausaufgaben machen
hausaufgaben nach eine scheiße
ab morgen schule wann freitag abend
übrigens als lockstoff ich schon ich bin
dann einfach abgehauen bin nach hause
war fix und fertig und ko und habe erst
mal elf stunden geschlafen bis heute um
15 uhr in canmore noch überhaupt nicht
klar was für eine verrückte nacht ich
weiß nicht ob ich so was schon mal
passiert ist einfach so nächten mit
total gestörten geschichten aber wenn
euch so eine schon mal passiert ist dann
könnte die und in die kommentare
schreiben
und wie immer durch das leider bitte pro
tage lassen kann ein kind in norwegen
gehen ja das war's für heute ich dachte
also diese geschichte ist so strange du
kannst du muss man einfach mal erzählen
wenn ihr mehr solche geschichten haben
wollte ich habe schon noch ein paar im
petto könnte das die kommentare
schreiben
feedback alles mögliche of stories in
die kommentare jemals die fleißig kommt
hier auch leicht
mit wachs das von heute von mir schon
reinmacht